Das war mein erstes Mal E-Zigarette –
und ich als Nichtraucherin muss sagen:
Sie hat gar nicht mal so schlecht
geschmeckt, nach Mango nämlich.
Die Frage, die ich mir stelle, ist:
Sind E-Zigaretten wirklich gesünder als
herkömmliche Zigaretten? Und wie sieht
die wirtschaftliche Lage weltweit aus?
Die Werbung nimmt den Mund ziemlich voll.
Rauchen ohne Risiko scheint da möglich.
Und das Marketing geht auf.
In den letzten Jahren nahm
der Konsum rapide zu.
Allein in Deutschland verfünffachte sich der
Umsatz von 80 Millionen Euro im Jahr 2012
auf etwa 550 Millionen Euro im Jahr 2018.
Ab 2019 gingen die Zahlen zurück.
Der Grund: In den USA und Kanada
starben Dutzende Menschen,
nachdem sie E-Zigaretten konsumiert hatten.
Nach den Todesfällen
geriet die Branche unter Druck.
Das heißt, es gab teilweise wirklich Einbrüche
von 50, 60, 70 Prozent
bei den einzelnen Einzelhändlern
aufgrund eben dieser Verunsicherung.
Doch Studien der US-Behörden zufolge
war der Hauptgrund für die Todesfälle,
dass Verbraucher ihre E-Zigaretten
mit THC-haltigen Ölen streckten
– sogenannte E-Joints.
Die Verunsicherung blieb. Dennoch ist der
globale Markt weiterhin profitabel.
Vom Umsatz sind die USA weltweiter
Spitzenreiter in diesem Jahr,
gefolgt von Großbritannien.
In Deutschland liegt
die Prognose bei rund 870 Millionen Euro.
Doch in 41 Ländern ist der Verkauf verboten,
darunter Brasilien, die Türkei und Indien.
Hier müssen Menschen sogar
bis zu einem Jahr ins Gefängnis,
wenn sie gegen das Gesetz verstoßen.
Mit ihrer Entscheidung
wolle die Regierung
besonders junge Menschen schützen.
Die indischen E-Zigaretten-Raucher,
auch Vaper genannt,
können die Entscheidung
allerdings nicht verstehen.
Mit Vaping habe ich es geschafft,
mit dem Rauchen aufzuhören.
Und dann, als ich aufhörte,
waren die Vorteile groß.
Ich hatte meine Ausdauer zurück.
Meine Gesundheit wurde besser,
und ich konnte wieder besser schmecken.
Ärzte warnen davor,
E-Zigaretten zu verharmlosen.
Zu sagen, dass E-Zigaretten
ungefährlicher sind als normale Zigaretten,
ist eine irreführende Information,
gefördert durch die E-Zigaretten-Lobby.
Eine Lobby, die der Onkologe
seit Jahren kritisiert.
Aber sind E-Zigaretten wirklich so gefährlich,
dass man sie verbieten muss?
Ich spreche mit Katrin Schaller vom
Deutschen Krebsforschungszentrum.
Es sind auf jeden Fall deutlich
weniger Schadstoffe in dem Aerosol
enthalten, als in Tabakrauch enthalten sind.
Das ist auch kein Kunststück,
Tabakrauch ist ja schließlich ein Gemisch
von Tausenden von Substanzen.
Das Problem: Gesundheitliche
Langzeitfolgen sind noch nicht erforscht.
Entscheidend ist aber tatsächlich:
Was passiert langfristig,
wenn ich diese Produkte
täglich mehrfach und wiederholt
und über Monate und Jahre hinweg nutze?
Und das weiß man im
Moment eben noch nicht.
Fest steht: Vor allem bei
jungen Menschen besteht die Gefahr,
dass süße Geschmacksrichtungen
zum Konsum verleiten.
Und so verschärft auch Deutschland künftig
die Gesetze. Die Bundesregierung legte fest:
Ab 2021 darf online nicht mehr für
E-Zigaretten geworben werden.
Händler befürchten große
Umsatzeinbußen für die gesamte Branche.
Und ab 2024
ist auch Außenwerbung verboten.
Das heißt: Plakatwerbung,
Litfaßsäulen und so weiter.
Und das halten wir für einen großen Fehler.
E-Zigaretten zu vermarkten,
wird weltweit also immer schwieriger.
Und ob sie gesünder sind als herkömmliche
Zigaretten, ist noch nicht ganz klar.
Langzeitstudien zu den gesundheitlichen
Auswirkungen von E-Zigaretten fehlen noch.
Tatsache ist aber: Sie hinterlassen keine
Zigarettenstummel auf dem Boden.
Für mich ist die E-Zigarette aber keine Option.
Ich bleibe lieber Nichtraucherin.